well I understand you are a Star Trek
fan absolutely that certainly was a show
inspired a utopian future inspired by
technology I'm curious what about that
show shaped your vision of an optimistic
future I I was a sucker for Star Trek
when I was a kid even though when you
look back I think they're only 20
episodes right they just looked over and
over again but they're always fun to
watch what what made the show I think
lasting was it wasn't actually about
technology it was about values and human
relationships and which is why it didn't
matter that the special effects were
kind of cheesy and bad right they've
only won yeah or they land on the planet
and you remember there's all this paper
mache boulders there and but it didn't
matter because it was really talking
about an ocean of a common humanity and
a confidence in our ability to solve
problems and you have a recent movie I
think captured the the same spirit of
the Martian I mentioned that is my
favorite movie last year not because it
had a hugely complicated plot but it
showed a bunch of different people just
trying to solve a problem and employing
creativity and grit and hard work and
having confidence that if it's out there
we can figure it out and and I do think
that what I love most about America this
country why it continues to attract
people from all around the world for all
the challenges that we face is that
spirit of what we can figure this out
and and what I value most about science
is
this notion that we can figure this out
well we're going to try this if it
doesn't work we're going to figure out
why it didn't work and then we're going
to try something else and we will revel
in our mistakes because that is going to
teach us how to ultimately crack the
code on the thing that we're trying to
solve and and and if we ever lose that
spirit then then then we're going to
think lose what's essential about
America and and what I think is
essential about being human and I know
they well yeah the only thing I would
add I totally agree I love the optimism
but I also think that it's amazingly the
Federation's very diverse Cruz very
diverse it's a bunch of diverse group of
people
and the bad guys aren't usually evil
they're just misguided or broken and so
so it's a much more optimistic view of
humans as well you know and then a lot
of shows that are about you know
superheroes or evil and in the end of in
the struggles are kind of wonderfully
sort of balanced well I think that's
right I think Star Trek like any good
story says that we're all complicated we
all got a little bit of Spock and a
little bit of incorrect and a little bit
of Scotty and maybe some Klingon in us
right but but this is what I mean about
figuring it out it part of figuring it
out is being able to work across
barriers or differences and okay there's
a certain faith in rationality tempered
by some humility which is true the best
art and the best science and
the best literature a sense that we
possess these incredible minds that we
should use and we're still just
scratching the surface on them but we
shouldn't get too cocky and remind
ourselves that there's a lot of stuff we
don't know
[Music]